um okay let's see here I've got a note
here let's see let's go to Alex I have a
note here to be worried that Alex
interrupts a lot so that's always a risk
but I had a note that his last call was
interesting what's going on Alex hi
David hi okay so my my question is so in
a video you did in October
you caught an economist who claimed that
the free market has failed when it comes
to energy and environment but then in a
video didn't December you said there's
no question in a free market that
renewables would surpass fossil fuels in
the next few years but we don't actually
have a free market because subsidies for
fossil fuels so are you arguing that
subsidies determine which energy source
is drawn because wind and solar get much
more in subsidies per megawatt hour so
let's see I'm not understanding the
question so you've cited a couple of
videos but what what are you actually
asking me I'm asking are you arguing
that subsidies determine which which
energy source wins because wind and
solar get much more in subsidies when it
comes down to the wire in what way do
they get more they get more bike per
megawatt hours so per unit of energy
produced okay but why do you get much
more right why are we why would we why
would we measure it that way in terms of
the subsidies which ignores a lot of
both the economic realities and
environmental priorities I mean it seems
arbitrary simply to say if it's true and
I don't know if it is that the subsidy
is higher per megawatt hour like what
what does that tell us about what's
right to do well I'm saying these are
like like there's the production tax
credit that wind and solar get and this
this tax credit keeps being renewed
you know if since 1986 they've been
I'll keep let's keep keep it up because
you know only a few more years wind and
solar will become competitive with
fossil fuels but you know they keep just
renewing this and giving these tax
credits for producing wind and solar
electricity ok and therefore what and
well I'm just wondering I guess my
question is do you support a free-market
approach or do you support in a
regulation that slows down the
production of fossil fuels so there's
you recognize there's the difference
between regulation to slow down fossil
fuels versus regulation to speed up
renewables right would you grant that
those are two different things
sure you would okay so my position is if
we are going to say that we want energy
to be produced on the basis merely of a
free market then we've got to get rid of
all subsidies on energy production right
now
even though you may be right I don't
know if you're right but you're you've
asserted that on a per kilowatt-hour
basis the subsidies are higher within
some renewables programs in total the
entire country's economy is based around
both the use of and maintaining
political stability for and
subsidization of fossil fuels so I would
be willing to take a position that we
should actually let the free market
figure it out accounting of course for
negative externalities I think that if
we identify negative externalities it's
completely reasonable to account for
that that would be one approach I think
that another approach that I would also
be open to is if the government if we
grant that the government has an
interest in ensuring the persistence of
our planet it would be a completely
reasonable thing for the government to
do to say we are going to encourage via
economic policy the development and use
of
energy types that are not damaging to
the planet so I I'm open to both of
those ideas okay
can you name a Direct Subsidy the fossil
fuel industry yet like which one would
you get rid of first I would get rid of
all of them and no I don't know the
names of the program so you've cited a
program from the 80s I'm sure that
you're not being dishonest about that I
don't know what the subsidy programs are
called but what we do know is that the
reason that gas costs what it costs here
is because it's heavily subsidized by
the federal government okay I just know
all the names of the program for example
okay well you know Massachusetts where
you live and they get seventy percent of
their energy electricity from natural
gas okay and they import their natural
gas from Trinidad and Tobago because
it's it's so cheap it's cheaper than
coal so how is how is that subsidies
that are making that the case the the
particular example you gave doesn't
refer to a subsidy but that doesn't
negate the fact that fossil fuel
production in the u.s. is heavily
subsidized you've just cited a statistic
of it a little gas and Trinidad and
Tobago
right right what these unspecified
subsidies you mentioned I mean one of
them is the Home Energy Assistance
Programs so it's it's basically like
food stamps for energy helps low-income
people pay for their utility you know
that's considered a subsidy and the
harvesting and production of fossil
fuels all right Alex I appreciate the
call I think we kind of know we can tell
what your position is anyway